so I'm Shawn parent I'm a prince
scientist at Adobe Systems out in
California I've been at Adobe now
depending on how you count about 22
years I started my career there on
Photoshop and now I'm actually back
working on Photoshop again but I did run
a research team at the company for about
eight years
with Alexander stepping off on the team
for people who who know who alex is he's
the person who created STL um this is
one of my favorite talks that I give on
runtime polymorphism but with five
people in the audience here if you guys
want to hear about something else just
raise your hand and I'll talk about
anything I'm here for you guys so a
while ago let's see I guess it was about
three years ago now at the going native
conference at Microsoft I gave a talk
called C++ seasoning and I got a lot of
requests after that talk to write a book
so my agreement has been that as I get
asked to do additional talks I try to
flesh out a chapter from the book so
this is kind of the outline of the book
and this talk fits in about here it
doesn't matter if you haven't seen seen
the other talks I'll give you the
background information this just gives
you a little bit of background now all
my talks have a goal the goal for this
talk is to write code without
inheritance the reason why I state the
goals in the negative there
non-prescriptive right I'm not trying to
tell you what to do instead although
I'll present some alternatives here but
I'm going to present the problems that
inheritance cause causes and and it's I
as a goal it's an open-ended issue so
it's like it's like strive hard to not
use inheritance but if for the problem
you're trying to solve it's the best
tool you've got in your toolbox then use
it
so it's not a rule it's not a guideline
it's a goal so what is inheritance right
so inheritance is a mechanism to
implement runtime polymorphism where one
class is derived from another class but
overrides all are part of that
implementation okay now here we're
talking about class inheritance there's
other forms of inheritance there's
protocol inheritance but in this talk
we're talking about class inheritance a
quick disclaimer in my example code to
keep the code readable I I'll leave out
header files inline function namespaces
things like that they're just ignored
for clarity so I've a little IDE here
for my slides so we can write main and
this will output hello world that's the
idea here
so we're going to develop a little
library in our library we've got some
object type which for now is just an
integer okay and we've got a function
that can draw our objects by just
streaming out our integers okay we've
got a document type which is just a
vector of integers sector of our objects
and we've got a draw function to draw to
draw our objects right so fairly simple
that's my library some client code might
look like this we create a document we
add four objects to it and we draw the
document and that will output this
okay
so some quick guidelines here right all
code as if it were a library right right
reuse of your code increases
productivity for you and your entire
team and writing unit test is simplified
if things are factored out into a
separate library
so what happens if we want our document
though to hold any drawable object how
do we go about solving that right right
now it's just holding one type of object
well the traditional way is we say okay
for any type of object will make object
via base class and it'll have a V table
under the hood okay it's going to point
to a virtual destructor and our virtual
we're going to virtualize our draw
function okay and now our document can
hold multiple objects right my class
type key some other type key right but I
can't store them directly in my document
because they're variable size male right
the different instances of different
types of of my objects in my document
are different sizes so what I'm going to
store in my document are pointers of
some kind
right so my library now looks like this
okay so I've got a base class for my
object type I've got my a virtual
destructor okay I've got my document
type to manage the memory I'm going to
use a shared pointer right that's what
most people do
right there and so my client code now I
can write a subclass and I can output my
document right I can put in my own type
right there and I can draw it okay so
everybody following the code fairly
simple so how many people see the bug
anybody
now
I don't have to declare it virtual
because it's in the base class it's
virtual yeah it works I can run it but
there's a bug there's a bug right there
okay so what happens is I come along and
I knew my object I called in place back
to put this into my document document
has to grow its size growing its size
can fail that would throw an exception
okay
I already allocated my new my class it's
not yet held by a shared pointer and it
leaks okay so there's a small bug right
there so that's why most people in the
C++ community will tell you never call
new directly okay just don't okay
instead call make shared okay so this is
a actually also more efficient for
another reason if I call make shared
then make shared is going to allocate
the reference count for that pointer
along with the object in a single block
as opposed to putting the reference
count in a separate block if I just need
the object okay so I have two wins there
that's exception safe and it saves me a
little bit of memory and a little bit of
time
okay but there's a deeper problem with
this piece of code right what happened
here is I change the semantics of what
it means to for copy and assignment and
equality of my document okay before when
I had my document and it just contained
integers I could copy it it copied all
the contents now it's copying pointers
to all the contents so I've got shared
data okay so you see
applause and then programming in general
we define an operation in terms of the
operation semantics so assignment is a
procedure taking two objects of the same
type that makes the first object equal
to the second without modifying the
second that's the definition of what
assignment means if I look at the
structure I've created I have shared
pointers in in my document now pointing
to a single instance of T and if I think
of those as the individual types right I
can copy my shared pointer that obeys
the rules for assignment okay but what I
fail to account to is the relationships
the arrows that those pointers point to
something and so if I take those into
account then I have intercept expecting
objects okay those intersecting objects
can interfere with each other so really
I have a single object that's this
that's all instances of the shared
pointer and what they're pointing to
okay so the structure is still copyable
undecidable but we have to do it through
other means the shared structure also
breaks our ability to reason about code
right anytime I'm reading a piece of
code and I see a shared pointer and if
you're coming from a JavaScript world or
a Java world or or a dotnet world this
drives me nuts and what I refer to as
the reference semantic languages right
which is all of those those languages
every time I see an object I do not know
who else is sharing that object right so
I don't know when I call a function what
are other effects that function is going
to have on the object that I'm hanging
on to so I always say a shared pointer
is as good as a global variable right so
we want to choose the same syntax to
have the same semantics that enables
code reuse and avoid common toriel
interfaces this is what the entire SPL
is built upon is this principle okay so
if a.type has a proper set of basis
operations
can be adapted to an alternate set of
bases operations regardless of the
syntax right so if I have if I have the
ability to copy an object then I have
the ability to to map that copy into
assignment or into a copy constructor
right now C++ has defined semantics for
operations on built-in types including
assignment copy equality and address of
ok ok now it's interesting copy
constructors are actually things that I
see abused the most I actually had an
engineer walk into my office one time
and said so I'm writing this class and I
want to be able to copy the class so
what do I call the member function that
does copy and I said well that would be
the copy constructor and he said no no
I'm already using the copy constructor
for something else this is a horrible
situation because the compiler
understands the semantics of the copy
constructor and the compiler canalize
your copies so if you're using your copy
constructor to do something without
copying then you really don't know
what's going on in your code ok so the
book elements of programming we say this
there is a set of procedures whose
inclusion in the computational basis of
a type let's just place objects in data
structures and use algorithms to copy
objects from one data structure to
another we call types having such a
basis regular since their use guarantees
regularity of behavior and therefore
interoperability right so a regular type
where the regular operations are
implemented with the standard names are
said to have value semantics copy
assignment equality right those are our
standard basis operations when objects
are referenced to indirectly through a
shared reference or a pointer the
objects are said to have reference
semantics right so shared pointer is
reference semantics an object in
JavaScript is reference semantics an
object in in Java or or in c-sharp
reference semantics
you
okay the next deep problem with our code
here when we went to the shared pointers
is the call to draw on my class TR often
interacted through virtual calls
including the destructor even when it's
not necessary okay
I'm always allocating my class T and
access to my class team must be
synchronized now if you're programming
in Java
some of this the compiler is able to
optimize around from you because the
compiler actually understands reference
semantics so it's able to do things like
D virtualization and move things into
into scoped memory if it understands
your code in C++ it cannot the compiler
does not understand reference semantics
and nor can it under the current rules
of the language so the compiler cannot
avoid heap allocation sometimes the
compiler can be virtualized the calls
another problem here polymorphism is
intrusive right the document that we
created here now that holds our object
key based class I can no longer put in a
simple integer right right I can know
right before I could so even if I have a
draw function on my integer right my an
my integer is a drawable thing but it
would have to inherit from object e and
that means that if I want to use
somebody else's class from their library
I have to put some wrapper around their
class to turn it into a drawable object
right in large systems this becomes a
huge problem right what you start to see
is every header file includes a ton of
header files in every object inherits
from a whole bunch of things
and the problem stems from our use of
the notion of the term polymorphic types
right all of these problems the
requirements of a polymer '[ __ ] type by
definition comes from where you use the
type okay not from the type itself right
so an integer is not a polymorphic type
okay my integer might be drawable okay
what I'm saying is there is a piece of
code within which I want to deal with a
set of types such as integer and my
object key based class and whatever else
I create okay
that share a particular attribute so I
want to handle those objects as if they
were the same that's what we mean by a
polymorphic type so when I use
inheritance to represent that
relationship what I'm saying is I'm
building the use of my objects into my
objects okay and what I want to do is
separate the use of my objects from my
objects themselves so there are no
polymer types only polymorphic use of
similar types exactly what I said we're
tightly coupling components inheritance
implies variable size which implies heap
allocation heap allocation forcers a
further burden to manage the object
lifetime and shared pointer unique
pointer all these things indirection
heap allocation and virtualization end
up impacting my performance of you
lifetime management leads to garbage
collection or reference counting this
encourages shared ownership and the
proliferation of incidental data
structures what's an incidence
incidental data structure it's when I
have have a data structure within my
code where I have no single object that
points to it so if I have two shared
pointers within my code holding on to
some element somewhere else that is a
data structure but there is no
collection of shared pointers that
represents that that's an incidental
data structure shared ownership leads to
synchronization issues right right if
I'm start trying to share these things
across threads it breaks my ability to
local reason
there's good as a global variable and
further impacts performance which leads
me to this line inheritance is the base
class of evil so let's do something
instead let's take our library here and
let's start mutating it ok this is back
to the original where our object is just
an INT okay so the first transformation
we're going to do is we're going to wrap
that int into a class okay so all we did
here is we've got our object key and in
cells down there at the bottom holds on
to it we're going to have a draw
function up on top that just knows how
to draw integers okay and we'll declare
a friend function for drawing or object
type that just knows that in order to
draw this object you're really just
going to draw the integer it contains
okay so all we did was we put a wrapper
around the int okay that was it
okay we're going to let the compiler
supply a copy an assignment operator
which is perfectly happy to do in this
case and that means that we can still
write the same code and it still outputs
the same thing right
transformation number one so by writing
a class that behaves like a regular
object we can increase its reuse
okay so next transformation let's take
our object now with our int and let's
heap allocate the int
okay so we're just going to let add a
level of indirection we'll store it in a
unique pointer
we'll use make unique so we don't have a
memory management issue okay so we're
still just holding now instead of
holding an inch we're holding a pointer
to an end simple enough okay do your own
memory management
don't create garbage for your clients
write this all the management of this
this pointer is inside of our class
that's where we want it right now
have to add our own cotton constructor
here now we can't rely on the compilers
okay so we'll add a copy constructor and
we make sure there's actually copies
copy copy the objects are equal and
disjoint
that's what copy means okay we're going
to add an assignment operator okay so
we're going to write our assignment
operator in terms of making a copy okay
and then do you mean the guts of that
copy right we're moving it here this is
kind of a scattered standard pattern
even though it's just an integer move is
the same as as as copy for just that int
I'm sorry that's not true because we've
got a unique pointer at this point so
we're moving the unique pointer over and
spilling the guts from the copy
okay so assignment is consistent with
copy generally if I create an object and
then assign to it it's equivalent to if
I can't be constructed okay so this
assignment satisfies the strong
exception guarantee that's a nice
property what do I mean by that I mean
if we throw in the middle of trying to
make this copy we end up leaving the
object in the state it was in originally
okay
basic exception guarantee is that the
object is is still satisfies its
invariants okay but it's in an unknown
State that's a whole separate talk okay
assignment like all other operations
must have supply the basic exception
guarantee and you notice we don't
optimize for rare cases like self
assignment right sometimes you will say
say you know if this thing is really if
I'm assigning it to itself right because
that can happen through a reference then
don't do anything okay so this would
actually go ahead and make make the
additional copy but self assignment is
incredibly rare and so the check to see
whether or not you're doing a self
assignment in your system is slowing
down the 99.9999 case in favor of
optimizing the point zero zero zero one
case so don't do things like that okay
so our code now same code still works
right so doing this kind of separation
sometimes you want to do it in code it's
referred to as a pimple pimple pattern
or handle body idiom okay
this can be useful for separating the
implementation of your class from the
interface so sometimes you can have a
private implementation here our
implementation is just an integer but
that could be some class sitting into
that CPP file and I want to keep all
those guts out of the header files right
structuring my code this way putting an
extra level of interaction is one way to
do that okay let's take a look at
something here we're going to decorate
our code it just so it tells us when
we're doing construction and when we're
doing copies
and here's old
piece of code so what's going on here
we've got a function that constructs an
object assigns it the value five returns
it as the result okay and then down here
we have object X which we assign from
function okay so our assignment remember
is written in terms of copy so what is
this going to print
director only anybody else
so he's correct and almost every
compiler this will print this it's not
guaranteed in the current standard but
it will be guaranteed in C++ 17 okay so
right now this is called a return value
optimization and the way it works is
that because I'm constructing object X
here my function reason well
my object key the result of a function
actually lives in the scope outside of
that function and so the compiler knows
that if it's constructing a result and
that result is going to be used to do
the return okay that's a named value
that it can construct it directly in
place in the object T this is what I
mean by the compiler understands what
copy means and so the compiler can elide
copies so if you have your copy
constructor doing something else you
don't know what your code is doing
because you don't know when when the
compiler is going to call it or not
okay so let's change Oh
just a little bit we'll construct an
object with X and then we'll assign it
from functions question
yes
correct so which we couldn't be because
the result is the local variable so
okay
so what will this print
anybody
then copy very good so where'd that copy
come from
assignment the copy came from right here
we actually wrote that copy right the
first statement in our assignment
operators make a copy so that's our copy
okay okay so we're going to rewrite our
assignment in this form okay what we
want to do is say don't take our
assignment in terms of a Const reference
take our assignment by value that
actually hoists that out of the scope
okay and then we'll just move it into
place okay
the general guideline here is to pass
sync arguments what's a sync argument a
sync argument is is is an argument which
is going to be stored or is going to be
returned from the function that we're
passing it to okay so if we're taking
something and we want to to basically
move it somewhere else or we turn it
which is a form of moving it somewhere
else we want to test it by value okay
the argument to assignment is a sync
argument so now that will print seat or
seat or okay we got rid of the copy why
because we lifted
okay so in our assignment we lifted out
the argument and now the compiler is
able to do return value optimization
from the value coming out of there into
the argument of X get moved into place
okay so now let's go back to our
document like this and we want to
reserve right right just so that we're
not seeing copies from our document
growing and then we're going to reverse
the document right and reverse is going
to do care wife swap all the way down so
what's this going to print anybody so
we're going to do two pairwise swaps
you know so we got our
structures copy copy copy copy copy copy
copy write all those copies are are copy
to a temporary and then copy across in
our pairwise swap right
provide our own swap and we didn't
provide now a move constructor for the
compiler so what we want is a move
constructor right which is the double
ampersand there so we're taking an
r-value reference right and our value is
a temporary swap in people of plus
eleven and fourteen is written in terms
of moves
so with move since we know that the
value being passed to us as a temporary
so or the user's cast it to a temporary
with the move expression which is what
move does then we can just steal the
guts of it
now that
to just move all of our members is
actually the default so all we have to
do is say this
okay
let's plus eleven and fourteen this will
get picked up by swap
we'll print that okay so we got rid of
all those copies
now here's a tricky one what does this
thing print okay all we did is we took
our object key and we wrapped it into a
struct okay and so now our our
construction we construct it with zero
and then we assign
through our function there okay so same
code as before it's just wrapped one
level destruct
our copies back okay this one drives me
nuts this is because of what I consider
a language defect okay for the move
assignment operator a non static data
member direct base with the type that
does not have a move assignment operator
and is not trivial okay so the compiler
will not provide a move assignment
operator okay on our some type key
unless all of its members our move have
a move assignment operator now the
reason why that's a flaw is if that
sentence there said said instead of
saying does not have a move assignment
operator said said is not move
assignable then our copy would go away
okay so because our code is move
assignable it just doesn't have a move
assignment operator which has a very
particular signature so we can't quite
get away with that so instead we need to
put back our copy constructor and
default our move assignment operator
which will just move all of our members
which is a unique pointer so that's
going to work fine okay
okay so we want to pet so we're going to
amend our rule here we want to pass sync
arguments by value and swap or move into
place a sync argument is in the argument
consumer return for this function the
argument to assignment is sync argument
however because of a language defect you
must write them will write a move a
segment operator
okay now our copy constructor now that
we have a move assignment operator we
can actually shorten our copy
constructor to that which is make a copy
which is an r-value and assign it into
place
okay so we fixed that
passing read only arguments passing are
values of sinc arguments do not require
a copy understanding this can greatly
improve the efficiency of your
application okay so if you didn't know
all of this these are kind of important
things to learn so let's get rid of that
and what should we do next year
okay the observation here is that our
constructors before they were taking
constant acts the constructors are
frequently sink arguments okay or the
arguments to constructors are frequently
sink arguments and so we're going to go
ahead even though they're just integers
and it's going to copy we're going to
pass them by value and move them into
place just to follow our own rule
okay now we want to make this
polymorphic so up till this point it's
we've only held string or we've only
held integers now we wanted to hold
strings so we can construct our object
with a string we'll do it the same way
but we can't store an INT model anymore
right so what we're going to store is a
pointer to a concept right in this case
our concept is drawable object right so
we want a concept for a drawable object
so
step 4 draw object it's just going to be
a base class for our implementation here
okay so we've got a base class which is
our concept it's got a defaulted
destructor and our string model and our
int model inherit from it
okay we're going to virtualize draw on
it so there's our virtual draw function
okay and we're going to provide a base
way to draw a string okay so fairly
simple set of transformations what our
codes getting a little messy in a little
while oh we also have to worry about
copy right so before we could just copy
our int model now we have to virtualize
copy okay so we'll go down here to our
concept and we'll add a virtual copy and
we will implement virtual copy for a
string model and our int'l
but now we can do this we can put a
string in here
and this will work so we've got a little
polymorphism but we've got a pretty big
class at this point right but we didn't
allow our polymorphism to complicate the
client code and we're working with
integers and strings which don't inherit
from anything so that's pretty good so
far the polymorphism is an
implementation detail and that's where
polymorphism should be okay but we have
a lot of redundant code here right so
what can we do with redundant code like
this right we've got to draw functions
that are almost identical right do we
have a language facility to just write
that once anybody the template right so
we're going to template eyes our draw
and we're going to sanitize our
construction okay now down here we have
to model implementations almost
identical one for Strings and one for
integers right well that could be a
template just a model
okay so now look what I can do I can
write my own class and I can provide a
draw function I could also just make my
class serialized to to a standard stream
and it would pick up my default draw
function okay so I can provide a custom
draw function or I can just provide a
stream out for it and now I can store my
class T inside of my documents okay my
class T inherits from nothing so
whatever I want it to be
okay it's called the runtime concept
idiom it allows polymorphism when is
needed without inheritance the client is
important with interfaces factories or
class delegations okay so I can adapt
anybody's third party code all I have to
do is is is provide a draw method a draw
function standalone function and I can
throw it in and use it with this type
okay
in fact since I started this whole thing
my document which is a vector of my
objects itself I have a draw function
because I'm calling draw a document see
out right right there's last line we've
been calling that all along so I can put
my document into my document okay and
that's going to work right and it's not
going to explode because it recurs
forever it puts the document into the
document at the state the document
within at the time that I copied it into
the document okay so now I can have a
document that contains 0 hello another
document containing 0 on hello into that
document my class key and of the second
document ok so you want to shift
polymorphic use you want to make sure
we're using regular semantics for all of
our operations that way everything works
with containers promote interoperability
and there's no prevent performance
penalty this code is as efficient as the
base class mechanism it is that's
exactly what it is under the hood ok so
but there is potential performance wins
because I don't have to wrap integers
into objects okay or strings into
objects or third-party library things
into objects and lug those things around
my system
now let me flip to a demo here
you
- play
is Photoshop for anybody who hasn't seen
Photoshop or hasn't seen Photoshop in a
while I'm actually back on the Photoshop
team when I first joined Adobe like
twenty two years ago I worked on
Photoshop for a number of years and now
I'm working on a Photoshop again so this
is a shot that I took of the at the
beach in California some people think
the seagull looks like it only has one
leg there so let's fix that
there we go so now the seagull
doesn't look like it has one leg anymore
let's do something horrible with this
image right I wanted if we were sky
let's paint in some lower sky
my favorite color
[Music]
someone checked there okay so why am I
doing this it's certainly not to display
my great artistic talent but over here I
have open what's called the Photoshop
history panel okay and even if I went
and did something like said take this
entire document and say let's just
revert it all the way back to where it
was okay my history panel is still there
and what does that mean
that means that I can back up through
every step of this document all the way
back to when I opened it okay so up
through Photoshop for Photoshop hat undo
but it only had one level of undo okay
now
during Photoshop
we said we want multiple level undo but
we had a problem and that Photoshop was
written using something called Mac app
which is a framework that Apple used to
ship and had these command objects and
the way it would work is a command
object would implement a bunch of member
functions for do it
undo it redo it commit it was the basic
model so you would write a command you
would implement those things and then
you would get undo well the problem was
over the initial Photoshop development
is is people were storing the data that
they needed in order to to undo redo
okay prior to commit hanging out in
fields of the document right well where
would I put this I would put that there
so if you did two commands back-to-back
the second command might clobber the
undo history for the first command okay
and this was kind of strewn throughout
the code right because you had to put
the data someplace in order to implement
redo so where do you do it you hang it
off some member of the of the document
and this was a problem the code base
even at that time was big enough where
it was like how in the world do we even
find all of these places and one of my
colleagues mark Hamburg said I have this
great idea let's get rid of that model
entirely all we're going to have is do
it just do it and between each do it
we're just going to make a copy of the
entire document everything okay no
Photoshop can handle massive documents
right like you know we've worked with
JPL to create documents that are the
surface of Mars to a one meter
resolution like the entire surface of
Mars to a one meter resolution as one
Photoshop image okay okay and our model
is just make a copy make a copy okay so
that gives you undo it gives you the
ability to step in and out okay so but
it also gives you more because I have
this handy tool where is my tool this
right here
called my history brush so I can come
along here and say well I kind of liked
a little more of the blue there so I
will anchor my history brush there and
come down here and say well I'll just
put back a little bit of that blue now
I'm not you see I'm not painting blue
I'm painting in the state document
within when I put the blue there okay
and if I say well no I want a little
less blue I can paint back in the
document in its original state maybe I
didn't want the blue over the sequel's
head okay so this feature came along for
free because Photoshop already had a
clone tool that could clone from one
document to another document and it
could clone from one point within a
document to another point within a
document and so if we have a whole stack
of documents right that's all our
history is is a whole stack of documents
that I can clone from one document into
another document so what does this have
to do with our talk well let's take a
look let me turn off
bring your rain ok so this is what
Photoshop does right right when we make
a copy of the document it's a very
lightweight copy right because most of
the structure is actually shared okay so
when we lay down a pink stroke the only
thing that's new is the titles of the
image with the paint stroke right
Photoshop busts the entire image into a
whole bunch of relatively small tiles
and that lets us just modify portions of
it so let's write an undo here
okay so what we want is our history
which is a vector of documents and we're
going to add the following commands
commit undo and current which just
returns the top of that vector okay so
all commit does is does a push back of
our document state push back to back
that's actually legal C++ and undo where
we can do a pop back
so we're going to write that now let's
go all the way back up here we don't
need to document our C tours but we're
going to look at copies and we're going
to take this code and we're going to
change it so we create a history state
and we do write which is we take our
current document and we put in 0 in
hello then we draw our current document
we'll draw a line and then we'll commit
that change into our history and then
we're going to take the now current
document we're going to put 42 World put
the document into itself and put in my
class draw it put a line and then we're
going to undo which I'll be back to our
commit state and draw the document one
more time okay so that's what this is
going to print construct our document
copy copy copy okay
and then we're going to display our
document like that and then we're going
to put it back to the state it was in
initially okay so each of those copies
come in because of course we're copying
our document to put it back onto itself
and that's going to copy all the objects
within the document and if you haven't
figured this out yet
I don't like copies so what are we going
to do well this is where all of our
copies are coming from they're coming
from a copy and assignment operator and
I don't like that so get rid of it
okay which means we don't need to
virtualize it so get rid of that but we
do have to make a change here right
right now our object would just be
movable with a unique pointer so let's
put a shared pointer in there okay but
at the start of this talk I told you
about how evil shared pointers were so
let's fix that the shared pointer to a
Const no place in this piece of code do
we actually modify this object the
internals of it right and an observation
is that for polymorphic use cases of
objects having mutable objects is the
extreme extreme exception where there is
benefit for that and there's a good
reason why so if I have a virtual
function that's mutating my object okay
then what I am doing one of two things
I'm either saying that my subclasses can
provide a different implementation okay
which that's very problematic because
that's going to change the performance
guarantees of those of that operation
and potentially a bunch of other
operations on my object or I'm saying
that my subclasses want to observe when
this thing is set but they're not
actually mutating it so rather than
having them override by my mutating
virtual functions what I should do is
provide an observer function where I
will call them when I have changed
things okay
so what we're going to do is make shared
like that and now
all of our copies okay and the code
still works and the code still has value
semantics
okay the side benefit here if I wanted
to come along and say in the middle of
some transaction the user hits command S
and I save this document I can just peel
off a copy of my document right I've got
document there in my ace and lambda
bound to my current age let's just make
a copy of this document so I can peel
off the copy of this document throw it
into a thread and draw it from the
thread
right and if you say I had a sweep for
three seconds there that's just so it
didn't come over and that's what this
would print okay which is the state of
the document at the time that I should
save it okay
there's no raise conditions there I'm
good and clean so this is thread safe as
well
okay so compared to an inheritance based
design is more flexible it's not
intrusive
it's more efficient polymorphism is only
paid for when needed
so which is a huge benefit so I find if
you if I look at most class hierarchies
people don't know they just like making
everything virtual right right right
they're like they're like well I needed
or I needed this to be virtual in this
one case so it's virtual everywhere okay
it turns out that if you write code this
way that you'll find that you need
actual polymorphic behavior in just a
few set of cases right instead of all
over in your code base so less
error-prone the clients don't have to
worry about heap allocation they don't
have to worry about object lifetimes or
ownership it's exception safe and it's
thread safe so we created think about
what we did here we created a little
library where we have an object type
that holds any drawable object where
drawable is defined as has a stream out
operator or its own draw function okay a
document of those
history state with undo and commit and
we did that in less than two slides
worth of code
okay so as we increasingly move to
heavily threaded systems using futures
and reactive programming and task queues
value semantics becomes critical to
avoid locking and to allow us to reason
about code right if you look in my safe
I didn't have any mutexes I didn't have
to lock my document just peel off the
copy and send it away
I hope the languages and libraries will
evolve to make creating polymorphic
types in this format easier if you look
at like language go has this built in
the language Swift has this built in and
I'll take some credit for for
influencing Swift I gave this talk the
first time over a decade ago at boost
con which was Dave Abrams conference
which is now C++ now it was a keynote
there and Dave Abrams is one of the key
designers on the Swiss language and so
go watch his talk from WWDC and you'll
see it's very much a copy of this talk
just cast into Swift right some thanks
there - Aleks dip not Howard Hannon and
Dave Abrams who've all provided input
into this a link there to where you'll
find my papers and presentations talks
from this conference of today's version
of this talk isn't yet up but it will be
before this conference is over and I
cited a Alex and Paul's book elements of
programming a few times in this talk so
that's the actual reference for that
book so it's a good book a difficult
read if you haven't read it before
so any questions
with that what are the drawbacks to this
approach
so the yeah so the drawbacks it's a
little difficult with this approach if
you have the equivalent of of multi
inheritance where you have a polymorphic
use case where you want to handle things
that are kind of of a variance they
either satisfy concept a or concept to
be it can be difficult to encode things
this way there are some ways around it
but they tend to get silver boasts that
I usually say if you are really in that
situation probably multiple inheritances
is the way to go another drawback
because this is non-intrusive also means
that it's not self documenting right so
when I have my class type that doesn't
inherit from anything but yet in order
to use it correctly it has to satisfy
the requirements of drawable all right
so it's just got the standalone draw
function there's nothing in the code
that tells you hey the reason why that
function is to err is so that this can
interoperate in this other place right
so there's a there's a pro/con there the
plus side is I can just lift up my
drawable object and drop it into another
system that has different polymorphic
requirements and I don't have to carry
some whole class hierarchy along with it
that's just extra baggage trade-off
[Music]
other than that I don't don't don't
really know of any so other than it can
be a little verbose to type like I said
I'd like to see a little more reflection
in the language to get rid of the
boilerplate
we
the conflict so the question there is I
have my draw if a library implements
their own draw will it conflict
potentially this is one of the downsides
of using a dl-44 name lookup which is
argument dependent lookup which we want
to use in this case because we want to
call draw and pick up the draw that they
implement so the idea there is is choose
your names carefully and know that their
hook point and sometimes that might mean
manually prefixing your names like you
know my class underscore draw whatever
or my library underscore draw so that
you're clear that I mean draw with this
semantics if it's a common name that's
probably a good thing to do so so that
leads into a whole discussion of why I
think you know ADL was the wrong
solution to the problem that tries to
solve and look at something
any other questions
any questions outside the talk okay
thanks
you're the rest of the conference